brian mast is a gop congressman from
florida a member of the house foreign
affairs committee and also a member of
the house transportation infrastructure
committee um thank you so much for
talking to us okay let's talk about
majorcase's words he says that
undocumented immigrants were quote
promptly removed if their claims don't
prevail he said the washington post in
fact says the opposite that one million
people who entered the country without
proper documents have actually been
given deportation orders and they still
have not left so the question is does
new yorkers suffer from fuzzy math or is
he flat out lying
well let's take the sentence before that
one as well they will immediately be
placed into immigration enforcement
proceedings well yeah that's true and
what are the the administration's
version of proceedings it's take them
into the country by a law enforcement
officer under homeland then put them on
a bus make sure to give them some health
care as well put them on a bus and send
them somewhere else around the country
to appear at a court date sometime later
in the future maybe two or three years
in the future maybe never that's what
immediately placed into immigration
enforcement proceedings
actually looks like so he's not lying
he's just not telling you the truth
right there where he does start to lie
is to say when anything is actually
prompt right it's not i mean i try to
teach my kids
words definition would be not telling
the truth but who who am i to say uh
critics this is the guy in charge of
disinformation governance board right
that is ahead of that i know i actually
love that title misinformation board
yeah they should they they they like
corner the you know the policy on
misinformation but anyway critics of the
biden administration uh border policies
say that their abandonment of ice
detention centers in favor of electronic
monitoring are called alternatives to
detention is what they call it um that
it's only exacerbating an ongoing crisis
at the southern border you lump that in
with the possibility of the eradication
of title 42 later this month
and what do you get
yeah you get this problem let me bring
you to something that happened last week
so i sit on the foreign affairs
committee i get a lot of delegations
from foreign countries they're members
of parliament secretaries of different
parts of their government you name it i
had a delegation in from guatemala last
week into my office and they were
literally blaming the biden
administration for what's going on in
their country they say listen these
coyotes they come on tv they run ads
saying if you give us five thousand ten
thousand dollars look at this this ad of
what joe biden is saying we can get you
into the united states of america no
questions asked this is what the
guatemalan delegation is telling us is
the problem as americans and what's
being aired on their tv this problem is
going across borders and it is because
of joe biden yeah there's a recent poll
that i want to put up on the screen
that shows that the majority of
americans say now is not the right time
to end the title 42 border policy when
asked is now the right time most
americans 57 percent say now is not the
time to end the trump era title ii uh 42
border policy i mean of all times to end
this thing
why now i mean what are they trying to
prove
well this is the only
covid policy that democrats want to get
rid of is the one that keeps people from
coming into america illegally it's the
only one they want to get rid of
otherwise they want to make sure you
continue to wear masks that you're
kicked out of the military if you don't
get a vaccine still and other things
like that this is the only one they want
to get rid of why because they
fundamentally believe in open borders in
letting people come across those borders
without without getting a covid test or
anything else without worrying about the
drugs they bring across the fentanyl the
human trafficking the sex trafficking
everything else that's going along with
it they don't worry about those things
it's an america last policy it's exactly
the opposite of what donald trump had in
place with america first policies remain
in mexico and that's just where that
party is at people try to try to
understand well why would they do this
that's why that's where their party is
at they're the party of open borders
yeah and you open the border they will
come and they will die here because as
you know you've seen uh reporting here
on this channel how migrants are
drowning by the dozens by the hundreds
uh you know people being killed or
losing their lives by coming into this
country we're allowing it to happen it's
a humanitarian crisis um to say the very
least uh congressman mask thank you very
much for talking to us
all the best i went to brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now